[MUSIC PLAYING]
INSTRUCTOR: In this
video, we're going
to discuss how to
view, use, and track
usage of promotional credits,
such as startup credits,
and your Google Cloud
billing account.
Let's get started.
To view your
promotional credits,
start in the Cloud Console.
Use the left-hand navigation to
head to the Building console.
Choose the billing
account for which you'd
like to view your
promotional credits,
then locate the Credits pane in
the bottom right-hand corner.
Click through to credit details
to see a list of your credits,
including the credit's original
value, remaining value,
start date, and end date.
If the Credits pane does not
appear on the Account Overview
page, it means that the account
does not have any credits.
Note-- it may take up to 20
minutes after redeeming credits
to see them in the console.
To use credits, make sure
your Google Cloud projects
are linked to the
billing account which
has the credits applied.
Note that promotional credits
apply to future use of Google
Cloud platform products
and cannot be applied
retroactively, so you are
responsible for any amount
accrued prior to the
credits being redeemed.
Credits are valid for the given
time frame after redemption
date, which is viewable in the
credit details you saw earlier,
or when the credits
are fully depleted,
whichever comes first.
After you've used
your credits, you
can track their usage at a high
level on the Cost Breakdown
tab, or you can
dig a little deeper
and analyze them
on the Reports tab.
If you use the Cloud
Billing exports to BigQuery,
you can analyze
your credit usage
by un-nesting the Credits field.
An example query is linked
in the video description.
Head over to the documentation
to check out more details.
[MUSIC PLAYING]